- Christina, so nice to see you.
I'm sorry I'm not Kelly Clarkson.
- It's okay. It's fine.
You're not bad.
- Oh, thank you very much.
I'll take it, I'll take it.
Happy belated birthday.
- [Christina] Thank you.
- You just had it recently, right?
(crowd cheering)
What'd you do to celebrate?
- So I took my first solo trip.
I went to Santorini, Greece,
London, Paris and Lisbon.
- Whoa. Wait a minute you did,
that's a big trip, you did that solo, huh?
- [Christina] Yeah.
- [Mario] Wow.
- [Mario] Well, there you are right there
with the solo selfies and everything.
What prompted that?
That's a very eat, prey, love
kind of move right there.
- That's exactly what it was.
I had been wanting to get
to Greece since I was 33
but then the pandemic happened
and I've been working so much.
I've done, you know, two
TV shows, two movies.
And when I finally got
some time, it was like
okay, I'm gonna go to Santorini and
I found the perfect place to go to.
I got a little villa,
and once I was in Greece, I was like okay,
I'm gonna go to London for dinner.
And then I went and met
some friends in Paris,
- [Mario] Look at that.
- And then my last place was Lisbon.
I just wanted, I've always wanted to go.
- Look at that.
(audience clapping)
That's so impressive.
- Yeah.
- That's so empowering.
I can't even go to the movies by myself.
And you went to the whole
that like, so many people-
- You, but like, do you need someone to be
in the movie theater with you?
You don't.
- You don't.
But I just like get mad lonely.
- Okay.
- You know what I'm saying?
I like how, but that's so,
that is a really cool thing to do.
- I'm not gonna, I was, I
don't wanna say terrified,
that's not the word.
But I mean, it is weird
like just being out by yourself so like,
you know obviously be safe.
- [Mario] Sure
- You know, check reviews and all of that.
But I mean-
- That's exciting too.
- Yeah. But now that I finally did it,
it's like, okay, where else can I go?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay. Okay.
Now I know you're
originally from New Jersey
and I'm assuming that's where you got
your start in acting.
- Yes. I grew up in a neighborhood
where there wasn't much to do.
I had very busy parents and
one day I was sneaking and
taking the elevator at school.
And this woman, she looked at me
and she was like: hey kid,
you wanna join our club?
And I was like, what club?
And she's like, the drama club.
And I said, okay.
I joined it.
She put me in her play
Grease, I played Frenchie.
- Oh, good part.
- And I was very unprepared.
I didn't, I was so nervous,
that I couldn't remember any of my lines
and she just was yelling
them to me from the wing.
And I felt so guilty about that
that I vowed that I would
never forget another line.
The next play she put me in
was Annie and I was Annie.
- Ooh, look at that.
Major step up there.
(crowd cheering)
Did the teacher continue
to to follow your career?
- Yes.
- And have y'all spoke since?
- So she has since passed
but when I graduated high school
she started my fan club.
- [Mario] Oh look at that.
- And she used to send me
checks to get to auditions.
- Oh. She's-
- None of which I ever
cashed, but I still have 'em.
And it just was her little
way of like just helping me.
And it wasn't much, but it was
the sentiment that mattered.
- So sweet,
that's a perfect example of
how important teachers are.
They really are, they
can be life changing.
- Yeah.
- So and cut to, you got a new movie.
- Devotion, it's based on a true story.
(crowd cheering)
Whenever a movie starts
off with the thing,
based on a true story,
I'm like, ooh, I'm hooked right there.
And in this one you play the wife
of a fighter pilot in the Korean War.
- Yes.
- Right. Did you have an opportunity to,
to meet the family?
- I did.
I play Daisy Brown and she is the wife of
Jessie Brown, Ensign Jesse Brown,
who is the first black naval aviator.
And you know, he, what his role
in the Korean War was, was 70 years ago.
So he's no longer here,
Daisy's no longer here.
And so kind of the
vanguards of the family are
her granddaughter and her daughter.
And you know, just in talking to them
and this being a true story,
even though they're not here anymore
you still want to honor them
and you wanna do the best that you can.
So it's just listening to the family
and you know, listening to the stories
and listening to just how much
Jessie loved Daisy and Daisy loved Jessie.
And you know, I think
in telling this story
people will see like a
really beautiful example
of just black love
between these two people
in the midst of all of this adversity.
It's the 1950s and you don't really see
real conversations
between couples back then.
So I'm really happy that we
got to do it in this film.
So yeah.
- That's beautiful.
I'm looking forward to
seeing that on screen.
- Thank you.